first of all congrats on the film uh had
a blast watching you guys
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies what do
you think would surprise people to learn
about the making of this film
we shot it in a lockdown and to further
add to that to further add to that
really after doing this
kind of day we shot this movie at a time
where we actually genuinely didn't know
if the world was going to go back to a
point of normality
we were in the height of that let me
stew away from our kids and our wives
and it was kind of like yo bro
if we die out here
just hug me slowly as i as i gently
drift into the night bro i just remember
do you remember we were like
going if we can't get back from prague
if they ground all the planes we'll
drive
and then we would go don't be ridiculous
and then we go we're not making that so
fast
we had this brexit issue so then we were
like are we even british nationals
anymore we're gonna be just nomads
wandering across prague for the rest of
our lives
so that was around there
just thinking about that like i don't
think people realize there was a time
you guys were filming probably when when
really everything was still up in the
air where no one really knew anything
exactly
we were filming in a time where it went
eight o'clock
everything in prague went
no one was on the streets not even cars
it was ghost town
uh and then until six in the morning and
we were off to work going
what's gonna happen to the world man
do you remember bro when i i messaged
you lot and i goes yo man
this is it i'm dead because i tested
positive on the way
on the way back into prague and stu was
really lovely not everyone's really like
don't worry because you're gonna make it
but they had a separate whatsapp group
they're like look at this [ __ ]
bmi he is finished
yeah we still have nothing in her head
i i didn't i'm glad that i didn't know
you got covered i'm just gonna say i'm
happy you made it through
i want to be honest i don't think i got
it i think it was one of those cheeky
false fathers here because
i felt i felt
relatively okay but it was just kind of
like just the fact that you're
mentioning that and the time that we
filmed it it is crazy to think that yo
we actually flew out there stu and we
did the movie magnus
yeah i i'm just curious um i'm a huge
nic cage fan i'm assuming you guys are
big nic cage fans
i love the fact that he's a part of this
movie but he's not in the movie well
maybe he's gonna be in a sequel imagine
imagine nick cage was in a sequel man
come on he
he could be he could have been a very
young father and he could be brad cage's
dad who'd be brad cagey's dad
well that would be
yeah that would be beautiful yeah i mean
i'm a massive i was a massive nick caged
fan it was like you know getting to do a
film like this
is like you know my my 14 year old
self's dream you know sitting in a movie
theater watching those films or watching
like corner on tv
and
so to do a film like this of this sort
of skill and all the action with like
zach you know you just go that that was
a total dream as a kid you know watching
those films
100 for what's your favorite nick cage
film i mean listen that's a that's an
impossible answer but in my immediate
mind i think face off yeah but
like i but it's an impossible answer
because
it's impossible there's no
best nick cage film no it's a witch cage
for which night film that's what it is
yes i agree with that
that's really good um how do you guys
actually um
uh how would you compare the tone of
this film to army of the dead what do
you want people to sort of know about it
i want to admit this myself i didn't
realize that there were absolutely no
zombies in the movie before we started
before we started filming and so
when eventually army did come out i was
like holy sh this is a this is genuinely
a completely different movie the only
through line that carries on is that
there is a group of people who need to
go and complete a mission a task a heist
but that's a really nice refreshing pace
because i think a lot of people often
complain oh my god it's a movie about
cars everything revolves around cars
this one is very different i think
there's a lot more i would argue
character development you get to see who
they are a little bit more uh and
obviously that was great being a part of
that you know were you happy or sad that
you weren't the one doing that bike
chase uh because some of those bike
stunts in the movie are like pretty
gnarly that stuff is uh that was
incredible i mean i saw one of the rigs
that they were doing
uh for down the stairs i mean that's the
proper set of like
check prague stairs that's like this
steep you know and this whole rig that
the stunt guys came up with
and that guy that you know is yeah it
was a serious sequence
all accompanied by the soundtrack of a
scream
totally
it's so pretty i'm
screaming i i was i was very impressed
with that stunt um
uh my last thing for you guys at what
point during the shoot were you ready to
just blow up that van and say
[ __ ] this van i don't want to film in
here anymore
i love that fan i love being inside that
fan because it was like a little dance
in there when it probably goes after you
had to do your driving stuff with the
volume with the screen eh actually that
that those days were
yes that is that is steve the official
[ __ ] this van day i was sat i was sat in
front of uh essentially it was a
motion capture of road it was a it was a
30 foot tall video that was playing that
was
essentially mimicking what i would do
when i was driving bro i've still got
inertia to this day it was a hot it was
hashtag after that day [ __ ] that van
official from steve collider